- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
So it's Sunday, late afternoon.
Late workout today.
Something good, yeah,
I'm rolling on that blue thing.
Where is it?
There it is.
Anyway, something
really good happened. What?
- [Jordan] Are you live?
- I'm not live.
I'm recording DailyVee.
Jordan said something
really good that excited me.
Here, I can't do that way.
Anyway, something good happened.
He tasted some humble pie.
He just asked me how
long was the video.
- 14 minutes.
- He just asked me if
the video was too long,
if it could be too long.
I said no.
'Cause if the content's good
enough he was talking about a
perfect chin-up video
and how it didn't hit.
Obviously since Jordan
started working with me,
his social media game
has dramatically improved,
as you can imagine.
Just like my muscles
have improved and,
fuck, man this back thing.
Anyway he's had some really good
success amplifying videos for
like a hundred bucks.
That's what this one was, right?
- Yeah, for a hundred bucks.
My social media
went from like--
- [Gary] No, no.
Don't tell them the highlights.
Tell them how you, this
whole episode will be like,
you know, I'm just thinking back
to the two or three
videos that I've made.
I like talking about the videos
that I knew were gonna be big.
- [Jordan] Got it.
- But sometimes they're
not big even though
I thought they
were going to be.
That's what happened to you.
- Yeah.
- And that's what's happening to
you guys all the time and so
I get it and this is a perfect,
you know it's like
raining outside.
Patriots are about to play.
(Jordan laughs)
Your video sucked.
They had a lot of
bad things happen.
A bunch of 'em got sad 'cause
they were thinking about their
two cents while people were
making three from yesterday.
It's a grind.
This isn't 365 days of glory.
Like, you know,
Jordan lost Thursday.
Seriously, he's like sitting
here he's like pondering.
He's like, "Why
didn't it happen?"
Think it--
- It was such a good video.
It was one of my best videos.
- No, no, you said it
was your best video.
- The best video I've ever made.
- But the market gets
to decide not you, Jordan.
- Exactly, I lost.
But I'll win, so.
- That's it.
Learn from your loses everybody.
That's the way it is so anyway,
just thought it was a really
interesting way to, I knew today
wasn't going to be a big episode
so as I'm sitting here just
literally just called DRock.
I was like, "Hey, put
something together.
"I'm gonna make a
one second video.
"We'll just do a mashup," and
then I was just thinking about
what Jordan said.
I said, "You know what?
"Wait a minute, this is exactly
what we should be doing today."
Which is, you know, the 365 day
world the truth is the majority
days are losses.
The majority of days it's not
going exactly as you wanted and
I do think you learn from it.
I do think that a perfect
chin-up video is fairly niche
and that's why or you
targeted the wrong group.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- You know, I don't know.
Anyway, have a good day guys.
See you tomorrow.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)